high hopes as Iran has been welcomed
back into the international fold and at
the Parliament the first real dialog
with MEP s took place we can use the
success of the nuclear diplomacy for
which we can all take pride and apply it
to the situation in the region see if we
can redefine the challenges and
opportunities in the region in a way
that is conducive to a positive sum game
but MEP wouldn't say positive bringing
up Iran's relationship with Saudi Arabia
their involvement in Syria and their
record on human rights during the two
and a half years of mr. rouhani's
presidency at least 2300 citizens have
been hanged including Sunni preachers
and currently detained bloggers and
journalists mr. Zarif was quick on the
defense human right is not going to be a
subject of political maneuvering Human
Rights is not going to be an issue that
you beat your opponents with the word
MEP is really beating up on Iran we're
coming from a situation of 15 years of
sanctions no dialogue taking place of
course huge mistrust on both sides but
what we've seen today is the foreign
minister having a very deep and
comprehensive dialogue with political
interests from across the spectrum in
the European Parliament Iran is a big
player anyway like it or not criticizing
the regime or not we have to deal
politically with this big country in the
region so nobody can ignore that so open
up the doors with Iran diplomatically
economically politically but the final
words went to the Foreign Minister wants
to work with the international community
while Iran is open to work with Europe
to reduce the concerns and tensions in
the region believe me we are not the
ones who have to gain your trust we both
need to gain each other's trust